joining me now from the denver broncos
formerly of the los angeles chargers and
of course the wisconsin badgers
is none other than kenosha wisconsin
native
melvin gordon how are you sir oh good
man
how's everything in denver treating you
it's all it man you know going well guys
are good the organization's good so
you know okay excellent and um
you know before we get into the football
aspect of things i
i am mandated with your hometown
in the news um what are your thoughts
when you're
you're seeing your hometown mentioned as
much as it is in the manner in which
it's caused your hometown to be in the
spotlight melvin
yeah um it's pretty sad man you know um
you know just we have to just do better
as a community as people
um you know seeing that man it was just
disgusting
you know it just made me sad because i
know that's not a direct reflection of
you know our community and what it's
about
um but it's just sticking in the sea
what was what's kenosha like as a
uh growing up what was it like for you
melvin oh
it was a good place you know um you know
i had plenty encounters with cops and
things like that
and you know it's a lot of good people
you know not too much racism around
obviously you know you have your
sprinkle here and there and that's
everywhere
um but you know overall it was a good
place you know we
never really got treated unfairly so um
you know just seeing that it was pretty
sad to see
so when you say encounters what do you
mean by that
just seeing like just you know you run
into cops you know you see cops all the
time cops do a lot of stuff in the
community
um you know you just see cops often you
know and
you know you never you know had a
incident
where i've seen where you know you had a
guy getting shot in the back
and things like that so you know that's
what i mean
no of course so it's so positive you're
saying when you grew up there were
positive
encounters with police which is
obviously what we're
we're all hoping to hear and hoping to
achieve and hoping to
to see do you still have um do you still
have family members
in kenosha yeah i got a lot of family
actually still is there
okay so what are what are they saying
what are you what what is what is going
on for
for them melvin um you know they were
just you know just nervous
um especially with uh you know with the
with the shooting that that was going on
down there during the protest and things
like that so
um but they're safe they're all safe um
you know and they're all fine now but
you know especially during that
you know during that time in that period
it was just kind of crazy for everyone
back home
melvin gordon here on the rich eyes and
show what have the conversations been
within
uh the broncos on this subject on social
justice what conversations have you had
as a team
together oh well we all had a you know
team meeting
on it and you know the day that you know
most teams that set out
um you know shout out to you know i
think detroit for really starting that
out um
[Music]
but you know we we got up there and we
discussed you know our we felt and
shared our
you know our thoughts on the situation
as a team and i got up there and i spoke
um it was good you know it was good um
that i let the guys know
you know how i felt it was good to know
how they felt so
um overall it was a good conversation
well would you mind
uh uh you you could you could uh turn me
aside if you wish
which i prefer not but that's the way
i'll set up the question
uh can you share what you shared with
your teammates on the subject um
you know just a general just you know
just a general idea
um it was just really hard for me um
you know seeing everything and i was
just kind of really emotional about it
because i couldn't be home with my
family
um during this time and uh you know i
just wanted to express to them
um you know if we could do something
whether we took a picture rather we
you know we tried to figure out
something here or something
just to kind of let you know my people
back home know that
you know that we all stand together with
them um
and that they were my family here and
that you know
i couldn't be with my family so i kind
of needed their support
uh through this um so you know and then
obviously you know i went back up there
and we had other conversations but
you know the main just when i i started
it out and i
kind of started out speaking around that
so
um i think he touched upon melvin gordon
here on the rich eisen show from the
denver broncos i think you're touching
on something that the nba players were
were struggling with considerably being
in a bubble
in an amusement resort uh when
when uh social justice needs to be
um achieved and fought for that they
couldn't be there they couldn't be
anywhere
except where they were maybe their own
hotels or this resort
um and obviously they took they took
action uh the bucks
leading the way do you think that
something like that
about not playing nfl games could happen
in the nfl
over the next couple of weeks that that
conversation might be had
melvin yeah i think i definitely
wouldn't put it i definitely wouldn't
put it past
us um collectively as a as a whole in
nfl i wouldn't put it past
us can definitely happen um you know our
time is coming or
you know people and teams and others
will look for us to make some type of
stand
and you know make some type of action so
um it's to be talked about it's
definitely conversations had
but um you know you know we'll
i guess we'll really hone in on that
when games come around and see what
happens so the conversation had
amongst players or but to ownership to
say
in the same way that nba players have
said we need to do something together we
need action items and we need money and
we need support and we need
verbal support from nfl ownership is
that what you're referring to
um yes but i think it's more so
that conversation is more so amongst
players
um i'm not sure entirely
it's amongst the owners um you know i
don't know if
you know they had conversations about it
but we sure
we sure do hope that you know if we do
make a stand they stand with us
melvin gordon here uh on the rich eisen
show uh let's talk a little football in
the few minutes i have left with you
here your role in the denver broncos
offense
is it going to look like something we've
seen from you before in college
as well as uh the los angeles chargers
melvin and uh man i hope so um
you know they really haven't given us
the game plan
um on what you know is to be expected as
far as refs or anything like that
um we don't know i don't know i
definitely don't know
and uh haven't asked um so
you know hopefully you know it's like
that um
i really don't like to come off the
field but you know
i don't know how they have things
managed i don't know how they're going
to manage the game with me so i i have
no idea so
you know my job is just to come out here
to work so
again i imagine you'd have a better idea
if there are preseason games and we
don't have them now
so you're saying essentially over the
next um
week and a half before your game that is
uh against the tennessee titans that
you'll
you'll you'll find out or you'll you'll
knock on the door of the coaching staff
and say
what's up i mean how does it how's that
gonna work do you think
oh man i don't know you know i wish i
could tell you i've never
really been in this position before you
know in the league
so it's it's a first for me um
you know so i'm not entirely sure you
know our situation is a little different
you got a guy that's been starting here
and then you got a guy that's coming
from somewhere that's been starting for
five years so um
you know i don't know i don't know you
know it's really a hard question and
it's more suited for them i guess the
head coach
what's it gonna mean when you take on
the chargers for you melvin that's
not gonna happen until november
obviously we're even wondering it's a
week to week moment right now not just
in
in terms of uh work but as you pointed
out life in general
but uh when it comes down to what's that
going to mean for you
um man to be honest it doesn't matter if
it's the chargers or
you know kc or whoever for the raiders
or
you know the bills and whoever we play
um
you know the mindset should be the same
it's to win and give everything i got
you know regardless of i shouldn't give
more because
i'm playing against the chargers um i
should give everything i have every game
so my mindset is the same going into
every game but i like to win against the
chargers of course but i also like to
win against everything but uh
you know my mindset is the same so it
you know it it doesn't change whether
it's
charges or anyone else a few more
minutes left with melvin gordon at the
denver broncos your
website is uh being launched today
uh melvingordon.org
tell me about uh what people can uh can
can see on the website and learn more
about you
melvin this is just everything and just
more so about me
um you know i definitely want to add a
lot of things that go on in my life
you know just just just you know make it
some flavor you know my foundation
things on that will be on there so just
be all around man it'll be all around
site
um you know it's definitely different
from the one i had
previously so you know i hope people
enjoy it okay
okay and uh beyond the flash your
foundation page is still available there
as well and again you spoke to jacob
blake's family
melvin you called up i i didn't because
you know it's just a rough time right
now my mom actually reached out to
i think uh his people okay i don't know
if she spoke to him directly but i kind
of just wanted to die down i know he's
getting a lot of calls and things like
that but
you know i just didn't want to overwhelm
him just so and then i heard he was
handcuffed to the bed and stuff like
that so i was just like man he's
probably just overwhelmed and things
like that so
i'm definitely going to shoot him a call
and be in contact but i definitely got
uh i definitely can't get in contact and
we'll be in contact with him okay and
then meanwhile as well and your world
uh your partnership with lids announced
this very morning you're the first nfl
player to partner
with lids yeah and um you got a new
custom hack design available later this
year we're seeing some uh some of the
hats that right now
it's pretty neat yes sir yes sir it's
decent man it's decent you know put some
thought into it
um you know i hope people like it uh you
know i'm definitely excited i've been
rocking live since i was a kid
and uh you know to be one of the first
nfl guys to be a part of that's great
you know some a company like that that's
been around for so long and just so
so known um it's awesome to me man it's
a blessing
honestly that i don't take for granted
and uh you know hopefully the broncos
country
and you know a lot of fans and and
family like that
that's exactly right we're seeing you
right now with a
lids uh visor uh i guess upside down
right there which is uh the way i wear
mine so my hair doesn't get caught in my
face as well
um so i'm also seeing here melvin i've
gotten information i'm wondering if this
is
correct or it's not that the first lid
you're putting on is a wolverine hat is
that a true story or that's that's is
that
am i misreading this on my card right
here
[Laughter]
[Music]
i've got my jj what what mug that he
gave me that i have to put out in front
of me any time there's a
well a wisconsin badger on it that's him
celebrating
as a wisconsin badger with the final
score of the game from this past uh
fall on it and the cups holds my tears
it says this cup holds rich eisen's
tears melvin
that's the way wisconsin badgers rolls
so before i let you go
advice for two running backs first one
jonathan taylor who we had on last week
i'd
love that kid he's gonna he's he's set
up for success what advice would you
give him or if you already haven't given
him
entering the last year just to learn as
much as he can from phil
uh a old wise vet man that knows the
game and love it
um you know feed off his passion
you know that he has for the game and
just learn from him you know watches
every move
you know the wavefield prepares for the
games and he gets ready and it's just
he just got so much mocking and you can
learn so much from him and the great
thing about it is
every game you're he's to the right or
left of you
you know so i mean he's right there and
feels just i mean he accepts everyone
with open arms he's willing to learn
so learn as much as you can from phil
man the savvy vet
and uh learn protection and ball out man
leave nothing
well he already uh he he says he doesn't
curse either jonathan says he doesn't
curse either so i guess he and phil
should get along very very well
oh yeah there you go you know that's um
and then um
last one for you the advice that you'd
give alvin camaro who is uh reportedly
missed consecutive
uh practices unexcused absences that's
being reported to be contract related
what advice would you give
alvin melvin oh just you know do it do
what your heart desire man
you know only you know what's right um
you know
you know go with your heart desire but
whatever you decision you make
you know just make it with 100 you know
don't don't make it with any doubt
you know a lot of people won't get in
your head and say this and say that but
honestly you truly understand how you
feel so go with your heart
melvin i appreciate the time i could not
imagine seeing my hometown
on television uh the way that i'm you're
seeing yours
um so i send only my best to you and
your family
and everyone in kenosha thank you man i
appreciate you baby always
always right back at you melvin gordon
check out his new website that launched
today melvingordon.org beyond the flash
is his foundation
and also check out his partnership with
lids he's the only one in the nfl as a
player who has it melvin gordon here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here